III it's over the press conferences are
done the announcements have been made
and boy did we find out a whole load of
new information but not everything
there's still a lot we don't know about
all the upcoming games as well as what
the big companies are actually thinking
until now this week on reality check
we're going to expose all the secrets
the hidden agendas and exactly how the
big publishers all really feel how you
ask well today we're gonna abandon our
faithful servant science and instead
take a turn to the dark side that's
right folks it's time to get pseudo
science we're gonna use pseudoscience
reverse speech now you may have never
actually heard of it but it's a very
real idea believed by dedicated few
reverse speech advocates claim that you
can get a glimpse of what people are
really thinking by recording speech and
then listening to what they have said
played backwards yes backwards how the
heck does that work well the theory is
that when we speak our brain
subconsciously chooses words that not
only makes sense for words but also come
together to make words or phrases that
reveal our hidden thoughts and
motivations
when listened to in Reverse lost don't
worry about it just type reverse speech
into youtube and you'll find tons of
examples usually heavily political
observe I for one believe there are
lessons to be drawn from her life
and from the extraordinary and moving
reaction to her death Celer
free live now seller we live now we live
now seems legit right well let's apply
this technique to this year's e3 press
conferences and see what we can learn
first I want to show some of the great
games coming to Xbox one and 2014 sir
sure we will further enhance ps4s
broadcasting capabilities but may think
it's actually not we can get it back no
we've never seen these characters this
real before no furlough York City
sometimes haven't you felt the need to
or the desire to scream at the
television screen look out behind you or
don't open that door now Michael the
road trip of your life begins
exclusively on Xbox channel the game
will feature completely new visuals and
gameplay sequences that will rival the
best ps4 games on the market epic will
be our roulette step will be our world
wet robots today we're dedicating our
entire briefing to games yeah it is with
hundreds of quests activities and
rewards but that's not all
so whether you're playing solo or with
friends bring you go close this is a
breakthrough in latency free
multi-device online gaming making I'll
not does not compete incident yeah it's
pretty cool ok so we learned a bunch of
things there surf games are back in a
big way Sony are into attack dogs and
robots for some reason and also Just
Dance doesn't need internet except
there's one problem it's all [ __ ]
isn't it I mean what possible
evolutionary reason could we have for
wasting all that brainpower just so we
could reveal our hidden thoughts and
motivations when our speeches listen to
backwards but you know what rather than
simply making fun of the pseudoscience
what's far more interesting is to ask
why but why have we developed this
tendency to hear words where there are
in fact none it's all down to something
called pareidolia it's the same reason
we see animals and clouds a face or a
rabbit on the surface of the Moon a
Bigfoot on Mars
Jesus on a piece of toast che
in the Rorschach inkblot test or faces
in trees I said faces it's a type of
illusion or misconception involving a
vague or obscure stimulus being
perceived as something clear and
distinct it's our brain recognizing
patterns something it does really well
and ultimately seeing something where
there is nothing to see so why do we do
it
well as famous science communicator an
all-around awesome dude Carl Sagan
explained as soon as the infant can see
it recognizes faces and we now know that
the skill is hardwired in our brains
those infants who a million years ago
were unable to recognize a face smile
back less or less likely to win the
hearts of their parents and less likely
to prosper but it's not just faces it's
also evolutionarily advantageous for us
to fail to pick out other things we are
motivated to see the Predators or maybe
prey but also to pick out things we are
motivated to hear like language also
once we are precondition to hear
specific words it's almost impossible
not to hear them
for example this clip will now always
sign to us like SAP there will be a
robot that will be our robot bring in a
new one however here we have Alex
Amancio discussing Assassin's Creed
unity
it sounds like nonsense right a second
listen for already at every job still
nonsense but what if I tell you he's
actually saying it's more of the bull we
did every year
now listen Laura we're going ready in
every job Laura we've already in every
job
well I'll leave you this week with a
bunch more secrets I pulled from the e3
press conferences
remember those two let me know what you
thought of this episode and the comments
down below or by tweeting directly at me
at camp for us Rob and also if you can
think of any great examples of
pareidolia I missed be sure to let me
know okay time for some more revelations
from the e3 press conferences thanks to
the wonder of reverse speech where every
single second is a story what you see
right here to tell us more is just
dancers executive producer mr. Jason
Altman nice touch their own military
they're a member of a civilian elite
trained in secret near name if I
remember this renewed interest and
excitement benefits everyone now we read
sniffing it November 11th on ps4
paralyzation um thank you for that
masterful segue today we are really
proud to announce a partnership with
Microsoft to bring a new type of
training on Xbox one
you may remember sir
first I would like to say thank you to
all the fans it's to be a surfeit so
last year we gave you a glimpse of a new
york city on the brink of collapse
smells vaguely worse pitting a couple of
ubisoft employees against each other the
u.s. against the france against the
france that's what they called it boss
therefore they got snacks with [ __ ]
Howie this generation is off to the
hottest start in history you're sitting
Krauts
you